welcome back subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this next segment believe in
being a positive force in the community
i stopped by to see what drives their
company to giving back take a
[Music]
look here at subaru of las vegas it's
more than just a car dealership they're
part of our community they're a family
they're all about spreading the love as
you can see behind me here and i'm
joined by general manager burton
hughes-burton thanks for always having
us out here it is great to be together
so you guys have a lot going on you're
always doing so much in the community
but let's talk a little bit about the
love promise what is that
the subaru love promise really is what
informs how we live our lives how we
conduct our business how we interact
with uh the public the community uh
every interaction we want to share love
and respect and really you know the
pillars that kind of support that whole
thing
our subaru loves to care super loves to
help super loves learning subaru uh
loves the earth super loves pets those
are the the five pillars and and uh and
that's kind of how we rally around and
and really get out there in the
community and do stuff so let's break
down those pillars for a minute because
you guys have teamed up with a lot of
different organizations in our community
i'll let you take the lead and start
with the first one that you want to
highlight
super loves to care is fresh on my mind
and we literally were just at summerlin
hospital and we were passing out uh
really neat blankets and
arts and crafts kits to uh to young
patients that that were battling
leukemia and so we work with the
leukemia and lymphoma society uh we've
partnered with them for years you know
subaru loves to uh to help
we we go out there and and
partner with great local community
organizations like red rock search and
rescue and the just one project we've
just given them checks of right around
twenty seven thousand dollars a piece
well super loves learning of course kids
are gonna be going back to school really
really quick and we love to support uh
the clark county school district and and
all the the educators out there and the
students we do back to school drives for
our kids as do many uh organizations
here we just gave a ten thousand dollar
scholarship to allison hill from vegas
academy of of the arts we partnered with
the castro verde law group and and she's
going heading off to college with ten
thousand dollars uh towards her
education so that's kind of cool teacher
appreciation week we adopt schools
emanuel cortez elementary school was one
that we adopted we also gave a thousand
dollars to guild gray elementary school
for pe equipment just doing stuff it
just it's what really we're passionate
about absolutely and i see behind you
there's some water cases um in this
truck here it's hot out here should we
touch on that as well absolutely because
that's that's one of the uh drives that
we're doing this month for july 1-31 we
are collecting cases of water for the
love well center and goodness gracious
ministries so you can drop them off here
at 64 55 roy hornway
8 a.m to 8 p.m uh pretty much every day
except for sundays and that's throughout
the whole month of july through the
whole month that's absolutely incredible
burton and before i continue i lost
count was that four or five pillars that
was only four but you know what subaru
loves the pets i mean you know we are
always doing things here we have 80 dogs
here this last weekend that we're being
adopted and and you know different
organizations that we work with uh here
in the community but i think we also
want to say hey we've got some great
rates still available
as low as 2.9 financing if you are
actually coming here to look at cars
for well-qualified buyers on on select
2022 models so we've got something for
everybody
the fill the boot fundraiser for uso
nevada is happening through the end of
the month at findlay subaru of las vegas
and for more information call
702-495-2100
and don't forget to take advantage of
their special offer 1.9 financing for
well-qualified buyers for up to 48
months on select 2022 models